i i think the majority of men don't even
get like
men's life generally average men is a
very lonely existence
whereas women women don't get okay so an
average an average woman yeah can walk
out of her house looking regular
in a track sea or like with a bonnet on
or whatever and still get attention from
it
[Applause]
and the average man walking out his
house does not get any attention his dms
are dry yeah he doesn't get any
attention sounds like a rough life right
i'll be easy out there though i'm just
saying that like the average guy doesn't
get the same thing that every woman
would get that's what andrew tate says
that like women don't know real
loneliness because there's always
someone that'll date a girl like even
like the girls on 500 pound life have
like boyfriends but
but
you get 500 pounds 300 whatever it is
no no they do they still but like like
that's what i'm saying what they call
feeders you guys just feed them yeah
yeah but i'm saying like like men don't
have that there's guys that oh my gosh
there's guys in my like that dm me and
like tell me really
sad existence stories like this one guy
no like this one is like he'll like dm
me and be like i'm addicted to hookers
because i like i've never been attention
i've never had a girl express interest
in me at all ever
because he probably doesn't know how to
communicate that's what i said because
the average guy doesn't know what
quote-unquote game is yeah
was like respectfully it has to be your
personality because i was like you can't
do this no no because he sent me
pictures and he like he's like black
pill and he's like oh it's over for me
and he's like am i like that ugly and i
was like you're kind of average looking
to be honest like it's gotta yeah it's
gotta be who you want i think he had a
degradation kink at that point you can't
change your personality man i know
something is morale it's just down down
the bottom
sorry men's is down astronaut sorry to
cut off something that is one of the
reasons why you and i experience when we
speak the way we speak the comment
section
a lot of angry men
like those are the men those guys that
i'm not i listen i'm about advocating
for men but a lot of guys who are quite
average who don't get female attention
get quite angry at that fact do you know
what i mean and they start to take their
anger and frustration out they become
the female versions of the feminists
that they criticize exactly and this is
too much it's like bro you need to calm
down maybe work on yourself try and get
yourself a personality try and go to the
gym or whatever you know i mean you
can't get yourself a personality
on amazon 20 off and one i think i think
true masculinity is like rare and i
think a lot of a lot of guys could bat
out of their league to be honest if they
were more masculine
one hundred percent because women are
attracted to me remember i talked about
it yeah yeah
you don't be you're not right because i
think we had this conversation like a
different show was that you it might
have been someone else like you don't
do you like care if a guy's masculine or
not no no you don't care that's not
because you're the aggressive one right
no
[Music]
already anyway but you also did you also
date like because girls my sexuality is
very fluid yeah and so is my identity so
i don't necessarily have a problem with
my partner expressing themselves on the
more feminine or masculine spectrum as
long as they're comfortable i am more so
somebody who dates someone for their
soul i don't really care i feel that yes
okay okay um it doesn't necessarily take
appearance for me to feel some type of
way about you you know i feel like if
the connection is there i'm genuinely
gonna like you yeah so what's the what's
the phrase when someone is in love with
someone because of their intellectual
capacity there's a word
i i feel like that [ __ ] that's what i am
i feel like sapiosexual should just be
like like everyone dates for some on
some level personality yeah
some people like to date dumb though
like
it's that trophy isn't it about having
that trophy person yeah i mean i'm not
gonna lie they like to feel better
knowing that they're the smarter person
in the relationship they want someone
they can put on their arm like this is
my partner look everyone don't speak
don't speak
or just say hi yeah just say hi
not even that but i don't know anyone
like that like i can't think of a single
person that i know in my personal life
that personality doesn't matter like of
course looks it starts with looks
there's so many like do you know so many
really
in my personal life in my dating
experience and it comes down to love
bombing doesn't it like how i attract
male 1 and at
[Music]
he looks great and then you get to know
his personality and you're like okay
maybe not so much
but then they they lump on you they get
you in this thing where their loved one
was like oh baby i love you so much
you'll baby girl oh yeah you're there
for me i want to marry you want to marry
you i'm like you got to be crazy you
don't even know me that well
you want to marry me i've literally
spoken to you for two i think guys just
like say that
they believe that it's going to entice
women to come in like oh you're my now
baby girl oh i love you so much baby
girl oh yeah the problem is
absolutely we call that simping over
here the problem is that it does catch
some girl's attention because i actually
lost a friend last year over this
um
because me and all my friends have been
telling her for like months straight
like this guy does not care about you he
just love bombed you then he disappears
for a few weeks not giving away as much
attention yes
like he'll like text her maybe once or
twice a day or like disappear for a
couple days like it just it was back and
forth now they're apparently together
but like
they had done it for a year like it was
a year straight that they had been
dealing with this bs and i'm like
how did you stick around this long with
this lack of consistency like this guy
just love bombed you one time but
literally the first time that they met
he said i'm going to give you my last
name now if a guy said that to me i'd be
like i need you to step back 10 17 steps
the thing is it's not simply it's a form
of manipulation it's a way to drag
someone into a relationship you make
them phone calls
though with the girl huh did the girl
just did the guy just want to have sex
with a girl that's what it seems like at
first but i guess not after a while they
ended up getting into a relationship who
am i to judge right but
they have other things going on so i was
thinking a basketball player last year
and i thought he was amazing like you
know we have this weird who draw i've
had a lot on here drop him drop his name
and at the time i just come out this
really like awful relationship he was a
he was a love bomber as well and they
all come back right they all come back
and it's like nobody's eating
but it's first sex that's why they come
back yeah
you're all coming back
see you later han you think you're not
gonna come back i can guarantee two
months time you'll be back no no no yeah
but anyways taking this basketball
player everything seemed really really
great right he was living in france he
flew me over to france and i got there
and this is a true [ __ ] story and i'm
gonna swear because show me his
instagram right now oh god and he
doesn't want me he presents me with a
rose in a box and i was like that's
that's cute okay that's cute you know we
spent the whole weekend doing it was the
first weekend we met we stayed in a
studio flat the whole weekend watching
squid games
[ __ ] not squid games okay then he
decided the next day he was going to
take this rose back to the supermarket
because you deserve better baby you
deserve the world he disappeared he
couldn't speak french i'm in there in
the supermarket speaking of french women
he wants to return this rose she's like
are you [ __ ] me i'm like no i'm
you you want to turn this rose one just
get another one sounds like broke [ __ ]
tendencies
like in in a box right so then he he he
said i'll come find you so i thought oh
maybe he's like planning this like yeah
surprise 45 minutes later and i'm stood
by some dead lilies he was like i was
going to get you these lilies like that
you know this is amazing i'm like dude
what is this like why did you you bought
me a gift and then you took it back like
i don't need anything i'm not expecting
anything so his love language was
is it gifts like yeah it's just yes
right so quite clearly because you know
that he thinks oh she doesn't even blew
you out yeah yeah he flew me yeah he
flew me out but that okay he flew me out
i was quite happy to pay right he flew
me out he didn't pay for luggage or
anything like that i paid for luggage he
pretended like the luggage thing wasn't
an issue which isn't a problem i don't
mind paying my way you do not you do
understand it for guy flies you're
always expecting sex right
uh we had sex once over one weekend the
first time we met we were watching squid
games is what means we were watching
squid games and you know what i found
out that he had a girlfriend all along
oh oh my gosh that's like
show me his instagram
let's not give him any air time though
no no oh my god basketball players as i
always say basketball
they ruin lives they're always like
do you know what when i left though and
i came back to london he then called me
up and decided that he didn't want a
relationship with me but that we should
carry on getting to know each other
because you know i said on what planet
do you live like i've just moved back to
london you live in france i'm i'm okay
thank you there are plenty of guys in
london that i could date who actually i
didn't know i had a girlfriend oh i
found out we find out we always find we
always find out
that's part of my job anyways
it's not going to tell their secrets
okay okay so so you were still connected
um okay one look at the following like
that's one
what
look at who's he following and then who
liked his pictures
go through the picture live
this was this was crazy he cried for 15
minutes on the phone begging me don't
you stay with him
a couple months later and i felt
i was in two minds i was like do i
message her that's not your business
don't do that that's not your business
[Music]
when it comes to women if you truly want
to stick by women and help them out out
of this shitty situation you've got to
call it out
he decided to involve you in the
relationship when he decided to [ __ ]
with you
guys unless unless a guy has a friend
who he finds out that his girl is
cheating that's the only time generally
as men that we go out and go to our
friends and say listen bro you know what
this
i've done it to girls i don't even know
like i was like i wasn't even involved
like like i've i've seen i've seen a guy
because i've seen her guys
but the thing is you don't know the
aspects of it already look at it i've
seen it i've seen a guy you're a human
being if they're in an open relationship
this person would have said so yeah
right they would be like hey just want
to listen to you no no if he's allowed
to do that you don't know
okay so what if he is then it's fine if
he is he would let you know because he
knows that you have no no no no no no no
no the one the one
i think there can be a compromise in the
same way whereby you could threaten to
say you sort this relationship out speak
to your partner oh i'm gonna do it i
think that could be you could give them
one
of you about that why would i don't tell
me what to do in my relationship oh my
god you're also not gonna tell me what
to do when you [ __ ] up relationships
you brought me into you
yeah but don't mind anyway